Hello,
and welcome back to the Rawkode Academy.
We
are live as always. My name is David
Flanagan,
And, today, we're taking a look at Kubevious.
Now before we get started, I just want
to encourage people to subscribe to the channel,
like this video,
and, remember, if I ever have audio problems,
thank you, Russell, for the comment, to let
me know early in the session rather than
just persevere with it. So if I sound
like a frog trapped underwater,
please leave a comment. But, hopefully, I sound
alright today.
Okay. Today, we're taking a look at Kubevious,
and I'm going to be guided today by
Ruben, a founder of the Kubevious project. Hey,
man. How's it going?
Very good. Hi, David. Pleasure to be here.
Thanks for having me. No. It's my pleasure.
I'm looking forward to playing with a new
project today. It's always my my highlight of
my week when I get sit down and
do something interesting and fun on top of
Kubernetes and hopefully solve a few problems that
I've got in the process. So
before I ask you about Kubevious, do you
wanna just take a moment to tell us
a little bit about who you are?
Yeah. Of course. My name is Ruben.
I'm the founder and CEO of Project Kubevious.
So in Kubevious, we're trying to promise engineers
to help their lives with Kubernetes
to improve overall Kubernetes and cloud native experiences
by making sure that we detect and enforce
and
detect through misconfigurations,
errors, conflicts,
or typos of that sort and violations to
best practices.
And we do that by correlating things that
are happening in the cluster and making sure
that any changes that you do are in
compliance with those practices.
I've been crawling for twenty five years. I'm
I've been in cloud native space for the
last six
years, and I'm really excited about the
that the cloud native and Kubernetes.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing.
Now I'm curious about maybe you can share
why you started Kubevious. Like, most people,
you know, they're just trying to solve their
own problems, scratch their own edge. Is that
true for you and Kubevious?
Yeah. Kubevious started as an internal project just
to help understanding what's going on in the
clusters.
As a simple UI, as a relatively application
centric dashboard,
which helps me understand, right, what kind of
applications I have in my clusters without
and what is the composition of those apps
without going into different types of resources
and trying to connect the the dots. So
for example,
in order to see how app is deployed,
you have to look at deployments, then you
would have to check services that would control
how apps are exposed to the outside addresses,
like volume mounts, config map, secrets. So it's
quite involved. And first of all, Kubevious started
as a dashboard,
which kind of, first of all, woah, shows
you the apps.
And underneath the app, it shows all the
links and all the references and dependencies of
your apps. Then slowly, the project evolved into
assurance platform. We started edit validations
because
and and we opened up the doors so
users can write their own validation rules.
And
we're we're we're getting very close to build
a fully pledged assurance platform for Kubernetes and
cloud native projects.
Okay. Cool.
Now I guess I what I'm curious about
is, like,
is it something that everyone should install in
their cluster, or is this targeted at people
and, like, an enterprise background, maybe, like, banking,
etcetera, where they have to have a really
good understanding or control in what's in their
cluster? Or is one of those things that
even if it's a hobby cluster, you just
deploy it because you're still getting that visibility
into it?
I think different users different types of users
may benefit and use different areas of Kubevious.
Like, for hobby projects, it can really quickly
help you get started with Kubernetes.
Let's say, you install a Helm chart with
few applications.
It can quickly let you know and make
things more obvious with Kubernetes.
Whereas for more complicated
deployments, complex deployments, like in larger enterprises,
they might more focus on RBAT capabilities,
like networking policies,
and writing their own more complicated
rules to be able to enforce those complex
scenarios.
Yeah. I like that you mentioned Helm charts
because I am very guilty of that where
I just go to the artifact hub and
go, oh, that looks like it might do
what I want, and then I do a
Helm upgrade install.
And, really, I have no idea what that
is like in into my cluster. I just
kinda have this level of trust, which I
probably shouldn't have with random Helm charts off
the Internet. So you're telling me that Kubevious
is gonna break that down a little bit
for me and show me what's happening?
Well,
it's not a it's not gonna give you
a complete safety of
it doesn't introspect the the workloads. It doesn't
check what it does. But at least when
the workload doesn't work well, there's some issues
with deployment.
You can see those things propagated all the
way up to the application level,
and then it it would guide you towards
the area that needs more attention.
Instead of showing things and analyzing
things in a, like, table form, it creates
a graph of the application. And dependencies are
kind of
you would find dependencies deep down. So it
does namespace application
and then container.
And then underneath the container, you would see
the volume mount, like the path where the
config map is mounted. And then underneath, you
would see the config map. And if for
some reason the config map is missing,
it would let you know in well, in
in advance.
Or if you're mounting
secrets to environment variables, if one of the
keys is missing, it would let you know.
And if you have any other issues of
that sort, let's say,
mismatch with labels,
naming issues.
So you can quickly detect those names and
then
at much earlier stages of your of your
deployment.
So Kubevious, as I mentioned, started as a
dashboard,
but the very recent development was ability to
enforce those checks and validations.
So you can plug it in into your
CD pipeline.
And let's say you have a package of
your manifest,
whether in the form of Helm or they're,
like, a directory within your
repository,
you basically just have to pipe all those
files into a special script. And if it
detects that,
the current cluster will be in a worse
shape with your change
Oh, I think we've
lost Ruben.
Oh, you're back. Hello?
Yeah. So I was saying so you would
have to pipe your
directory of your manifest or files
into a special script. And if with that
script, the state of the cluster would be
in a worse shape, then it would
let you know in advance, and it would
prevent
those changes from progressing further into the cluster.
Okay. So just to make sure I understood
that correctly in my in my head, the
Kubevious project, we've got two different components. So
maybe more, but two that I think I'm
aware of right now. One being we have
this user interface dashboard for what is inside
of our Kubernetes cluster,
but you're saying there's some sort of c
l I component that will allow us to
scan the manifest
and that kind of environment to give us
warnings before we push it into the cluster.
Is that correct? Yeah. Yeah. They're no they're
not two separate things. They're different
components of the same project.
Yeah. So
they're not kind of, well, divisible. It's just
a different ways of accessing to the enforcement
engine.
One is through the UI, which is continuously
running.
It's continuously monitoring any changes that is happening,
that are happening in the clusters.
And the other one is the enforcement tool
that kind of runs the same logic. It's
just it involves the changes that you're about
to apply to the cluster.
Okay.
So you said that the first version was
a dashboard and a UI. Like,
was that very intentional to build a UI?
Like, to make something that was UI driven
first? Because what I don't know. Maybe it's
just my my experience. But in the Kubernetes
landscape, we seem to be averse to UIs.
Although, I do see that changing now. We're
seeing a lot more dashboard like things coming
out. But that must have been quite a
brave decision or bold decision to be UI
first at the start. Yeah. It was very
well intentional. Probably transfer my background from gaming.
I used to do some game development before.
And in the very early version, you wouldn't
see it right now, but if I dig
a little bit, I'll find the older version.
So there is, like, a flat tuned to
have the,
like, layout
where you would see apps, and you can
kind of expand and dig into,
specific areas like apps and deployments,
pods,
or how things are mounted, HPAs.
And then you will see a tiny mini
map, like in strategy
games, in Age of Empires or Star Draft,
but then it lets you kind of navigate.
Yeah. It was pretty cool, but
at some point, like, being
more productive
became more important. And then we we got
rid of the mini map, and we we
edit a little bit different ways of navigating
this hierarchy constructor.
So
the thing with UI is
you can
put much more
accessible information using UI versus
just
being limited into a text. Even though, let's
say, projects like,
k nine s, it's really awesome. I think
they did.
They they got the most out of the
terminal stream. It's
you you kinda probably can do better. But
with the UI, you can provide a lot
of hints
on the same screen area
that wouldn't be too intrusive, but it would
be much easier to kind of
digest by the users with some hints that
allow user to kind of dig deeper into
further steps that needs more attention.
Nice.
Oh, my cabling's falling under my desk. But
Yeah. As long as we're still on the
air, I think we're okay.
Alright. You broke my heart a little bit
there when you said you removed the mini
map because Age of Empires was my favorite
game growing up. Absolutely. I I lost days,
weeks, and maybe even months playing that game.
It was so good. Yeah.
Well,
it's a it's an open source project. There
is older version. You're always working things for
the the new one. It's like, I think
you could go for 0.6
or below it would be the older version.
Well, I don't know if you've ever seen
this, but I think it was maybe two
years ago someone actually recompiled
Doom where all the enemies in it were
the pods within a Kubernetes cluster. So you
actually got Oh, yes.
Play Doom and shoot pods and, like, this
chaos monkey style game, which I just thought
was brilliant. Like, maybe we maybe we need
to do more with gaming technology and Kubernetes.
So maybe you're onto something here. Yeah.
I used to if you're familiar with the
game Quake, Quake Arena, Quake three Yep. I
used to write another
three d engine using OpenGL that uses the
same data. It just renders things in a
different ways with much
better shaders. So,
of course, it wasn't a full damage experience.
It was just a viewer of the of
the map, but
it it it it is quite fun to
take something that is old and
give it a little bit different thing.
Yeah. Definitely. I
I I would love to get some
some proper Kubernetes clusters and make a game
of it. Maybe even Age of Empires, like,
maybe I could build up my own pods
and then go attack some other cluster pods.
But that's not why we're here today, so
I'm not gonna go down that rabbit hole.
Yeah.
No. I've got the Kubevious website here. So
I'm gonna pull up my screen share,
and I'll move to miss them. I'm loving
that little animated sun that keeps floating around.
That's awesome. Yeah. So we're saying here that
Kubevious is going to avoid mistakes and cost
the outages. So this this
component you talked about is going to scan
manifest. We get application insights and the ability
to reduce problem resolution domain. So those are
three things that I would love to improve
on my Kubernetes clusters, and I I'm happy
that you get to guide us through this
today.
So
also have
a Kubernetes cluster with some fake workloads on
it and just so that we can use
Kubevious in a way that's gonna get us
a bit more data. So our step one
here is gonna be get Kubevious deployed onto
my cluster.
Are you ready, Ruben?
Yeah. Go for it. Alright.
So I'm gonna go through the is the
documentation the best place for us to get
started today?
Either Dots or the
GitHub project.
Yeah. I can probably do GitHub project.
Alright. Let's pop over here.
And let's
it goes to the organization
oh, you're using one of those org with
me. Those are kill. Mhmm. I don't see
a lot of those.
So your CLI is called guard?
So the guard is the enforcement part. So
we would use it
afterwards.
After we install Kubevious, then we could use
the guard just to
just before we would make the further changes
before you would
do another TubeControlApply,
which would use the guard. But we don't
have to start with it. And you really
have to have Kubevious
running in your cluster to be able to
use the guard.
Because the way it works, it communicates with
Kubevious, and then it kind of asks it,
hey. I wanna make those changes. Can you
just sanitize and just check what's gonna happen
in my cluster if I were to apply
this change?
Okay.
Well, I found the installation instructions. So we're
gonna create a namespace called Kubevious.
We're going to add a Helm repository,
and then we're going to install.
I am not familiar with the atomic flag
on Helm. Is that
important? It's basically says either install everything or
if something doesn't work, just uninstall.
Oh, nice. You don't have to. Usually, it
works.
But I don't have Helm according to my
highlighting here. So this is my
new
Mac Studio. So I'm gonna install and stuff
as required because my dot files were not
as complete as I thought they were. Mhmm.
Let's see.
Should hopefully just take a moment.
I hope you get the right helm. Have
you ever installed helm with apt get? Normally,
you get this random binary.
Yeah. I think it's 3.9 as long as
it's something
higher than 3.2,
but then it should work.
Well, we'll give this just a moment.
And then this is going to
create a port forward, and we should be
able to browse to local host 88. Yeah.
I'll just pop that open, and we'll give
him a minute.
Usually, it takes a minute or so because
it has to install Redis,
MySQL.
MySQL takes a little bit more there more
time to come up. And then there are
couple of microservices,
but those should also Well, we can we
can follow along. Right? So we could do
a Kubeflow,
Kubevious,
get pods, have a watcher.
Oh, wrong context.
There
we go. So we're just waiting on MySQL
to pass in its probes. Yeah. And we
should be good. Yeah.
Interesting time in Sam in the comments. What
does atomic do?
So
Ruben just said, atomic means that if any
component of the helm installed fails, all of
it will be removed.
Which is a nice flag. So I thought
I don't know how I'd missed it. But
Yeah. So for example, if that my SQL
wouldn't come up at some point, there is
some time in,
think, five minutes or so, so it would
start rolling back the changes.
Sweet.
Not that it always can roll back successfully.
That's a completely different story, but but look
at it. But at least it tries. Yeah.
It tries. Yeah. Alright. Let me zoom in
on this a little bit without
breaking the view.
I think we'll lose the bottom, but maybe
that'll be okay for now.
So do you wanna It does
yeah. Just one more quick thing. It doesn't
like zooming yet. We're using another library.
So after you zoom, you if you just
refresh the page, then it would come back
into a normal shape. Yeah. Oh, nice.
It's a bug. It's we're using the library.
Probably, we'll have to get rid of it
and
do it our own way.
Yeah. All all I have to do is
refresh. I'm happy with that. So Yeah. You
wanted to tell us what we're looking at
just now?
So that's the mainstream of Kubevious.
It's the place where soon we'll see
the contents of the of the cluster.
So there is a summary screen.
So it's supposed to load data from the
cluster right now. And then there are other
more specialized views,
like logic, images, gateway.
So
if we go back to summary, I think
it should.
It usually takes
much shorter. But
Okay. So what it's doing right now, it's
there is a process called Kubevious parser, and
it's supposed to load everything from the API
server.
And then it's gonna ship those manifest
to to Kubevious
engine, and then it would kind of correlate
all those things and show
violations
and errors
and just it should render the UI right
after that.
Right. Software
usually breaks.
Let's try to do that. That's how things
are. Right?
Do you if you just can you open
up the loads for maybe Kubevious parser? Yeah.
Can. Yeah.
So it's
it has some logic. It it tries to
query everything, then it, there is some
weights and checks.
There are certain
resources that it
tries to kind of load. Sometimes it doesn't
subside, and it waits a minute or so.
Usually, it should be shorter, but, yeah, I
think I don't see. At some point, it
at some point, it gives up and then
moves for forwards without those
CRTs.
I'm not seeing any
error message.
Am I just messing it? Sometimes
there are issues with metric.
Yeah.
Could it be my cluster? Can we check?
I don't think so. Can we check the
the other
process, the Kubevious pod?
Back end?
Yeah. The back end.
Just scroll up.
Okay.
Oh, we do have something. Okay.
Oh, one of the database migrations not run?
It should do it on its own. It
says that Kubevious notification snooze doesn't exist.
Oh, that's not a
that's not a good sign. So
so if we go you know what? Let's
do some dirty trick. If you can just
kill this pod,
if you can just kill this pod, it's
supposed to retrieve the the missing labels.
So you said the back end pod started
before MySQL was happy and it never Yeah.
It's supposed to yeah.
It's supposed to
it's not supposed to do that, but
okay. Alright. Let's give that a moment.
So we've got a hello from Siva in
the chat.
Hello, Siva.
And Sam's saying, good idea. You're looking for
the error message.
Yeah. We love a bit of live debugging
on this channel. That's for sure. Yeah.
So let's see what happens when we pop
over here.
So the way it works, so the parser
will retry
within
just a couple of minutes. It's actually
If I delete the parser, will that speed
it up?
No. There is no name. No. Alright. I
trust you.
We can just since we're doing more
more involved debugging,
maybe we can open up the logs for
the for the patent and see whenever there
is something coming in from the.
The other guy usually waits for a minute
before retrying.
Yeah. At least the back end. This looks
a much better shape now. Like, this is
Yeah. We don't see that error anymore. Right?
No. I don't see any errors. It seems
to set up a whole bunch of stuff.
So It could go all the way up.
Just waiting for the parser.
Mhmm.
So maybe we can do a better job
in kind of waiting for MySQL to come
back up before creating tables.
Have you seen the project schema hero from
a CNCF? I saw a CNCF project. Yeah.
It's really cool. Like, you can What does
it do? It does database migrations on Kubernetes.
So you you define your schemas
as
custom resources,
and it speaks to my scale and manages
all for you and handles the migrations and
stuff like that. It's pretty cool. Yeah. That's
awesome. I'll definitely take a look. There
was some activity on GitHub, so there was
a suggestion to use
MySQL and Redis dependencies
on
within Kubevious projects so that we don't have
our own ways of printing up
MySQL.
So it would kind of make our lives
easier, and kind of we would leverage
the existing helm charts for that. I mean,
migrations are the bane of every software project.
I don't think I've ever worked in a
software project where it the migrations haven't been
the most painful part. So
Yeah. Yeah.
Well,
let's
go back to parser maybe. Yeah. Okay. I
can take a look at parser.
Let's see.
If you go up, it there should be
some mention of postponing something for
I think it's complaining because there's no node
metrics, but I need to install metric server.
So it's supposed to just to skip it,
so it should be able to.
I can install metric server if you want.
Maybe it would take much longer time.
You know what? Let's
let's just kill this guy as well and
Let's just shut down my cluster.
Okay. And you're on maybe we'll do that
next. We'll try this. Yeah. Mhmm.
There's no demo that crashes first. Right? The
first one.
Yeah. Well, Kubernetes is hard.
I'm going to install
metric server just in case that helps.
It's very common for a metric server not
to be obvious, especially on home home environments.
So we specifically did something so that it
it's not gonna be an issue. But yeah.
Let's
see.
I it's okay.
I I don't I don't know if this
is is this better? Is this the same?
No. I mean, it looks
okay.
It's how it's supposed to be.
You said you have another cluster?
Can we try it out on that one?
And
Mhmm.
GBCTX.
I'll just use Docker desktop. Let's see.
Have a look. Meanwhile, I'll try to compare
the logs with my own lab.
Alright. So it's installing again.
So we'll give that just a moment and
then track the UI again. Yeah.
And I'll switch my contact then here so
we can follow along.
And it's getting there. Not long.
We have a lot of support in the
the chat. Sam says,
love this live debugging.
And, Kenneth, I think, guys can do it.
Keep trying.
Don't you worry. We're we're here till it
works. Right, Ruben?
Yeah.
There's no limit. Right? It's I hope you
can look at our plans. So
Yeah. Alright.
Let's just wait for my SQL and see
where we are. I'm
just gonna cancel a couple of
meetings at the dinner area. And
Alright. Just waiting on the probes.
So
that should keep helm happy. There we go.
Refresh the UI.
So now we have to wait a couple
of minutes for the data.
Kinda got the same screen. Is that good
or bad?
Is it
so you canceled the other one. Right? The
port forwarding for the other one, and now
it's from the Yep. This is our New
one. New cluster.
Let's check the logs for that one from
the back end. Yep.
Oh, yeah. So this is the
migration again.
Is it?
I'll delete the back end. Quite. Yeah.
Let me see. Okay. Let me see which
version
do we have on the demo.
That's
very weird.
Let's try this.
Oh, I just deleted it again because I'm
an idiot. Sorry. I
meant to get the log.
There you go.
Alright. No error messages.
Looks happy. Mhmm.
Oh, look. We have a UI. Okay.
Finally,
it only took two clusters. Right?
Well, my first cluster is a managed Kubernetes
cluster. Maybe I don't know if there's RBAC
things that need to be tweaked in that.
So
we'll just disregard that one unless you use
this one. Mhmm. David,
if you can just shoot me the logs
for that one that didn't work, I wanna
kind of get hold of it.
If Yeah. I'll give you access to that
cluster after the session. Don't worry. You can
you can put it. Works. Yeah.
Alright. Tell me what we're looking at now
then, please.
So this is
probably the first thing that you would wanna
do is to look at the browser section.
It's really from the left side navigation screen.
So the summary, it gives you the top
level summary of the cluster and, like, some
metrics, how many apps, namespaces,
what are the resources within the clusters.
And
below that, it will show you the top
three namespaces that you misidentified
issues
and
top three issues
within your clusters. So,
for example, since you don't have any other
workload, so probably the that's why the Kube
system jumps up to the top.
But
there are lots of service account
service accounts that nobody is referencing.
So it's it's considered a warning until you
have a full control whether you wanna disable
that warning, made it a error.
So you have control for those things.
And
yeah. So that's that's kind of informational.
The next thing you would wanna do, maybe
look at the logic
logic tab.
This is where you would see your
namespaces,
your apps.
Yeah. Maybe okay. Now you can see things.
Alright. So you will see the Kube system
and Kubevious.
If there is not too much interesting stuff
in Kube system, we can kind of
introspect
Kubevious.
So you you just click on it,
and it would show
apps
within Kubevious namespace.
And
below, you would see your alerts,
what kind of alerts it identified, and what
are the affected object. And
every single node within Kubevious has its own
sets of properties.
More often than not, you would see the
YAML traffic on the right side,
unless those are some synthetic
nodes within the UI
or some other sets of properties. Nice. It's,
like, bringing, like, this familiarity
I have with, like, my coding IDE to
my Kubernetes cluster. It feels very familiar right
away. Like like like, I'm using Versus Code
in some capacity.
Only the details we get in are much
more specific. Yeah.
Yeah.
And you can dig deeper. So, for example,
you you can try to open up the
the Kubevious
backend,
the very first node.
And
it would see show you the composition of
the app, how many times it restarted,
how many calls there,
how many of them are ready.
So that's a little bit of health related
information.
Mhmm. And
if there are some other
issues there so for example, there is some
warning on the deployment. Right?
And probably says that there are no resource
limits over there.
But yeah. So, for example, you would see
a spy icon
on top of the service account. Yeah. I
like that little bit of text there.
Yeah. So that's also clickable. Just just go
for it. Just click on it. And the
reason it's it has a spy is that
it has a full cluster access to certain
CRDs,
and that spy icon indicates that
something
it doesn't mean something is wrong. It's just
this workload workload
has an access to things beyond the namespace
where it is.
So just to be aware.
And the icon propagates all the way up
to the to the namespace.
So on top of the namespace, can see
there are some workloads that are doing things
cluster related that go beyond their namespace.
Yeah. I love this little resource role metrics
down here showing it kind of what I
can do. This would be great software for
clustered, actually. I bet you this would save
the meantime to recovery Yeah. A lot.
Yeah. So you do this on the roll.
Right? So you don't really have to dig
so much down to the roll. You can
see that on top of the service account.
Oh, yeah. So if you have 15, say,
15 bindings and 15 rolls, so it would
kind of combine all all them into a
single
table so you can quickly understand
what is allowed in the end of the
day to my workload.
Very cool. I like that. You can yeah.
Yeah. So different types of nodes have different
sets of properties.
So for example, service account has this table.
If you have network
policies, it would show which apps are allowed
to talk together.
And,
yeah, on the top level, you have, like,
resource uses usages,
how much of the overall cluster resources does
the entire application consume.
So
if you have addresses,
they would show differently.
Yeah. I like this kind of breakdown of
the images as well used within the application.
Yeah. But I can see here this is
from Docker Hub, and it could be as
back end Yeah. Tag.
It's a really Yeah. Really smart way of
presenting what is quite a lot of overwhelming
information to people when they adopt and learn
Kubernetes. Mhmm. Kinda making it consumable Mhmm.
In a way where you don't need to
just, like, throw your hands in there and
say, oh, I don't know. Like, I like
the Yeah.
I'm just gonna keep clicking on this for
random until you tell me to to just
Of course. Of course. Yeah. I think that
no matter how much the clip, it wouldn't
crash anymore. So
we're good. As when it starts working, it
doesn't stop working.
So we looked at the
we looked at the kind of logic view.
Right? But there are other different ways of
looking at the same cluster cluster and applications.
The other one, maybe we can look at
the images tab.
Mhmm.
This allows you to look at your cluster
from the images and replicators point of view.
So it would show that are you in
I have hard time seeing, but, so there
is a Docker Hub, and
there's another repo that you have. Yeah. There's
Kubernetes.GCR.io,
which I assume is the control plane component.
Yeah. We have Docker Hub. Yeah. So you
can click on the Docker Hub, and you
can see there there are seven images from
Docker Hub used within my cluster. And then
you're trying to can kind of drill down
into
the image.
You can see which tabs are used,
by which namespace, and by which which particular
app.
Yeah. Nice.
Cool.
Yeah. And then you can see the details
of the app. If you wanna drill deeper
into the app, you can navigate using those
target links, the very first
group of properties. You can click on it.
This is clickable,
and then it would navigate you to the
other view.
Yeah. So you can see the composition.
So it allows you to to kind of
travel
from one view to another, and
each view has its own sets of properties,
and it's composed in different ways.
If you were to use
or
traffic proxy,
you would see
gateway populated with domains and URLs and services
and over
there.
Probably the next interesting one would be RBAC
or if you have Helm charts, that would
those would populate in the packages.
Okay. Well, I mean, this is my local
Docker for Mac. So the gateway tab, probably
not that useful to us. What's the the
package tab here?
So
as of right now, it would show your
helm helm helm releases.
Ah, okay. So this is why I'm seeing
Kubevious because Yeah. So it
will show version one,
and it will show what what is their
contents and which apps are installed using this
Helm Relay.
And, again, it would
map it to apps within the logic view.
Can I show you the helm values fail?
No. No. I I don't even know if
that's available in the cluster. I have I'm
not sure. I'm not
Probably.
I don't know. Maybe I think they store
it a good way, actually.
I don't know if you have It's it's
loaded from a secret. Yeah. That that's a
good idea. Yeah. Yeah. Because it would be
cool to see,
alright. I've got this chart deployed. How did
I configure it? Also, of course, I have
this stuff in GET as well, but but
just for there's a lot of cool stuff
here.
Yeah. Alright. So the We have an idea
to yeah.
Go ahead.
No. I was just gonna click on the
Kubernetes tab, feel free. You go first, and
then we'll we'll move on. So so regarding
that package tab, so we had an idea
to integrate our Rawkode CD applications within that
package tab.
So those are kind of different ways that
you would deploy apps, and we
have to do a little bit of digging
how much is possible to do so that
we can kind of understand what kind of
apps are deployed with our Rusty, what's the
contents, and what things are coming from hell,
what is coming from Rawkode.
Nice.
Alright. Three more tabs.
Kubernetes
tab. Is this just
It's just a a resource browser. So you
have CRDs, anything you can kind of dig
down by namespace,
API.
Oh, yeah. If API extensions kind of resource.
Yeah. Custom resources.
Cool. And I can see all the CIDs
registered. Oh, nice. Yeah. Okay. I like that
bit. Yeah. That's cool.
RBAC.
I hate RBAC.
Alright. Well, we have a whole tab for
this. I won't click on it here.
This is my notes and storage. Very nice.
Not very interesting on Docker for desktop, but,
you know Mhmm. On on my other cluster
would be pretty cool. So in the public
cloud, if you have multiple node groups, so
it would separate the nodes based on the
node pools, node groups, depending on which. Oh,
yeah. Because all the provider you are. All
the notes have topology aware annotations.
I guess you're breaking them down for people
so that a lot more visual.
It's just based on the annotations.
We we try to match with the
known ones.
So if you're
from the major public clouds, then
it it would work for those.
And the RBAC. So this is basically the
same thing we did for service accounts. It's
just it would show
permissions allowed to users and groups.
Yep. But my customers only have one role,
cluster admin. I just give everybody cluster admin.
So I just keep stars everywhere. I like
stars. Yeah. But I think there should be
other ones. Right? They're about 11.
Yeah. There are more. Go by.
Yeah. So if you go to maybe second
one or
it has much more
bindings, and you can see that the matrix
gets
much more complicated.
But you don't really have to dig into
each individual
binding.
You can see what is allowed to that
user.
Awesome. This is something not really available in
in standard Kubernetes.
You have to
go
roles and bindings one by month to kind
of figure out what is allowed to that
user. Here, it's like showing those
those bindings in a reversed approach.
Yeah. Based on the how how would you
would approach the the bindings in the in
the role?
Yeah. You've got this kind of
pattern, which I'm really appreciating as we browse
around, where you have these little icon annotations
that immediately kinda draw my eye, and I'm
like, oh, there's there's something about this one
I need to be aware of. So the
fact that these service accounts are are shared,
so you've got cascade independence as you kinda
write the call out here.
And this you know,
I'm sure we've seen this on the logic
with the the pods as well. Yeah. And
you've got, like, warning and stuff. So I
like the use of that little tiny bit
of iconography across place, which is quite consistent.
It just pulls my eye towards it, and
I'm like, oh, I should take a look
at this and learn a bit more about
my cluster. So nice touch.
Yeah.
Thanks. So that hand icon, it comes from
Windows
era with the
from the shared folders. So the idea is
that, let's say, you wanna jump in and
make changes to this binding
because you need to make changes to your
group. Right? So what it means that if
you were to make changes to this binding,
it would affect other users or other bindings
as well.
Yep. Got it. So that resource is used
in other places. And to know which other
places it's used for, you can just click
on it. It will show what are the
other places it's used.
So it says shared with
this other play. Yeah. Kubebly config.
And Yeah. And it and it's also clickable.
You can see what is it.
And over there, it would say it's shared
with this
with this group.
It
just shows what would be the blast radius,
what would happen if you were to make
changes to this config map or secret or
Yeah. Or the binding or the role, let's
say.
Okay. And just to clarify, like, Kubevious is
read only view of my cluster. Right? Like,
it doesn't give me the ability to modify
anything. It's there as a way to inspect
and understand what is actually going on within
my cluster.
Yeah.
It's
it has been highly requested to to allow
you guys to edit things. It's probably one
of the things that we try to push
back with.
Once we start making changes to the cluster,
we're we're getting into a very scary territory.
But
we made some users happy if you go
back to Logic, if you or open one
of the manifests.
Let's say if you can drill down into
anything, service account.
So yeah. So
if you can make this config bigger,
there is a maximize button on the top.
Yeah.
Now you can click on the pen. It
would get into the edit mode.
So it cleans up unnecessary things like manage
fields. So you can edit in place and
either copy and paste or download this file.
And so
with
and it's read only. Yeah. And you can
also choose what would be your tab size,
two or four.
I like two. But, yeah, you would you
would download the file or copy and paste,
and then if you wanna apply changes,
just
go for it, but Kubevious cannot
do it for you. Trust. I think I
I like the way it doesn't allow me
to do any direct edit in the against
the cluster. So I'm gonna I'm gonna say
that's good.
What's this timeline view? Oh, this is changes,
errors, and warnings over time. Okay.
So this is the time machine. It shows
you the hard bit of the cluster. Maybe
we have to wait an hour or so
just to get more data populated.
But you can see three series.
One is the white line which shows the
amount of changes happening in the cluster.
The red and
amber are number of errors and warnings within
the cluster. And, usually, what you would say
is that
you may make a change that would cause
a spike in changes,
and it would lead to increase in errors
or warnings.
And that particular
time, you can just click on the chart.
It would activate the time machine,
and anything you see on the UI
would be frozen to that particular point in
time.
And you can do your debugging.
You can see why things worked before, why
things didn't work before,
and kind of slide it a little bit
left and right and see how
it was.
We can later on, if you want, we
can open up the the demo portal, which
already has some
data pile populated,
or we can
wait a little bit. And towards the end
of the session, we can try to see
how things change.
Okay. Well,
let's zoom this back out a little bit.
I'll zoom in as required. But
that's the that's the browser tab. This is
our single pane of glass and to everything
inside of our cluster from applications,
containers,
helm charts,
Rawkode, Rawkode,
and even CRDs.
So, yeah, that's a that's a nice feature.
I'm liking that.
Are we gonna move on to the guard
tab next? Yeah. Let's let's go. Do you
have some changes in mind that you would
want to apply
to the cluster?
I mean, we can definitely think of something.
Yeah?
Let's create a deployment and and
try to apply to the plaster. Let's say
some some trivial app, maybe engine names or
something
like that.
Well, let's see. And
we did deploy
I thought I deployed metrics server.
I must have deployed it to the wrong
cluster. Oh, well.
Alright. So we want to deploy need the
metrics. Yeah. Engine x. Right? So
let me just say Kubevious
directory.
Pop open code.
Wherever it is.
Mac.
Oh, no. I'm gonna quit it and open
it again. I don't know what's going on.
My computer just said See, it's not it's
not only Kubevious that
does it for the first time. It's a
it's a pattern.
Oh, that is funny. Alright. Yeah. So I
have a small tiny monitor in front of
me that runs a preview of the stream,
and my Versus code is heading behind So
I'm gonna have to turn
it off for a moment
and then move it and then take it
back.
Why are you there, Kube? Come on.
There
we go.
Alright. Computers.
So, yes, I trust this. I'm gonna create
an nginx dot yaml,
and we'll spec out a deployment that runs
nginx.
Is that enough for us to play the
card? You
know what? Let's let's make it more interesting.
Let's let's
let's have a another config map within the
same namespace,
and let's mount it as environment variables.
Okay. NGINX
password
secret.
K. Yeah.
And you want to do an ENV
from Mhmm.
Config map
NGINX.
Okay. And to make things even more fun,
let's make a typo either let's
engine double edge or, either in the reference
or yeah.
Okay.
That's fair. Yeah.
So you want me to apply this?
Since let's assume we're in a in some
CD pipeline before doing KubeControl apply,
we wanna
kind of sanitize and kind of check or
link those changes whether decide whether they're good
or not.
So let's go to the guard. It should
have
just one or two lines of instructions.
So this is what it wants. It wants
you to
basically pipe the contents of the manifest into
a special strip,
And that script would
take those manifest. It would upload them to
the cluster, and then Kubevious would be listening
to any change requests. And then it would
reply whether it passes or not.
Oh. That is right. Yeah.
Some point, we're going to have a self
fully self contained CLI. It's just this was
the faster
fastest way to get this out and running.
Alright. Let's see. So this is reading the
input, pausing it,
building some sort of package.
We have some It has to
yeah.
It's creating the
resource,
which is
oh, okay.
Does it work?
Let's go to the UI.
Maybe I didn't see if the file was
broken, but
oh, maybe I did. I'm not sure. Okay.
When we come back here
Yeah. If you click on it.
Okay. So it has two changes. You can
click on every single change.
Deployment.
EMV
from config map prep. Engine nine. And now
the other one.
Yeah.
Okay.
So
can you go to the validators?
Mhmm.
So this is the list of
all the checks that Kubevious can do by
default.
So one of those should be
okay. Unresolved conflict map reference container environment variables.
Yeah. So if you click on it
okay. So it was supposed
to
is it by default optional?
It's in the header.
It's supposed to be error.
It was supposed to fail, to be honest.
Yeah.
Let's do
can you try to add the optional false?
Yep.
And then just run this again?
Yeah.
Oh. Oh. Alright.
Alright. Let's then if it says it's good,
let's let's apply those changes with TubeControl
apply.
But let me tell you one thing. This
the guard is relatively
new development
even though it should work,
but there are sometimes
issues with that.
Alright. So we have our create container config
error from the conflict map being unable to
resolve.
Oh, okay.
Can we can you reference the config map
from not using from
from,
but using just the mapping
referencing the data?
Yep. So we want name.
Correct.
And then oh, and then config
ref.
And the name. Name
engine x
pick.
I think that's valid. I can't remember the
last time I used that syntax.
Let's see.
Okay. We have to
Well, there's there's a lot a little bit.
There's a lot of validators here. Let's try
another one. How about Mhmm.
Let's
let's add a service. If you can add
a service and reference the the NGINX.
Alright. Let's do it.
So blah blah blah.
Service.
Engine x.
And you want me to break the selector?
Yeah. I wanna use another selector. Yeah.
Alright.
And we'll run our validator.
Okay. Something is off. Something
is really off.
It's probably something for the demo?
No. I think
let's get back to the guard and see
if at at least it could kind of
record the the attempt for changes.
Yep. I can see the service here.
It's metadata name,
fake engine apps,
and the other one is not
fake engine apps. Right?
Yep. There's no fake engine.
Let's apply that change as well. I wanna
see if we would see the errors in
Kubevious.
Oh, wait. I got something wrong.
Okay. Explain
deployment
spec
template
containers
dot env.
Oh, value from
Yeah. And then config.
So that was that probably was my fault
then. So
value
from.
Try that again then. Okay.
If you go back to the okay. If
you go back to the EMV from.
You can do that.
If
you open up the file.
Mhmm.
Okay. So there is an array. EMV from.
Okay. This
looks good to me. My explainer says I'm
wrong. Oh, it wants a key. It wants
a key.
Inside that.
Yeah.
It wants a key.
The name and the key can be it
can be password. Right?
Name is engine x fate. The
Okay.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
Now let's try.
This is so odd.
Alright.
Looks like
regardless what we do, it kind of takes
the changes. It's it's it's says it's all
good.
I wanna see what's going on in the
browser. It
it takes five minutes to refresh. There is
a pause of five minutes after every
after every single change is detected.
So if we go back to browser, we
should be able to see that in in
the default.
Yeah. Okay. Click the button. Now. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay.
So it could see all those errors. Like,
if you maybe open
make the window a little bit bigger from
the, like, bottom
tool window,
So you can see all those errors under
the alerts.
Yeah. That was it.
Oh, yeah. Could not find contact with that.
Yeah. Okay.
So the drawer doesn't work.
Alright.
Yeah. I'll
we'll we'll have to take take a look
and see what
what's going on. But
Well, this is open source as you. So,
you know, do request welcome and open issues.
Whatever you think about, you'll open an issue.
Yeah.
Can we do one more thing? Yeah. Of
a process.
If can you restart the guard pod?
Yeah. Was the service guard definitely on?
Yeah. It's on there. Okay. Alright. Let's restart
it. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
We have logs from that pod?
Yeah.
We should.
There is a guard if you can open
up the logs for it.
Can you get logs, Rick, of this
UI?
UI doesn't have logs, but
most of the things are in the back
end and the
I'll draw this here.
Can you just chill it?
It should come up pretty quickly.
What happens if I run a guard just
now?
It it
it it will just take longer to run
until.
Yeah. That's
I'm really surprised because,
I would think that it couldn't kind of
there would be an issue with hydrogen delivering
those, manifests.
But yeah. So the promise is that it's
supposed to run the same changes
based on what changes kind of issues that
you would see in the browser,
but it it's supposed it was supposed to
prevent those changes.
Let's
can we do one more thing? Yeah. Go
for it. Can you I'm just guessing.
Just add a namespace reference in your manifests.
Just add a namespace default.
And you want me to run it again?
Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. Okay.
I'll have to take one
One more issue request.
Alright. Alright. So in this validators,
this is how it was supposed to work.
So if it hits an issue
from this validator's list, if it's
in a error,
if it's marked as a to be treated
as an error, then it was supposed to,
prevent those changes from getting to the cluster.
If it's disabled or it's at the word
level, it would be informational.
Okay.
That makes sense. Yeah.
Same would be kind of with the rules.
So rules allow you to write your own
checks
before writing new rules.
Maybe
that's a little bit more advanced, but maybe
let's try to look at existing ones.
And if you really wanna write your own
rule, we can use the browser that would
help us writing the rule a little bit
so we don't have to do it from
the stretch.
It consists of two tabs, two tiny little
bit of scripts.
The target is supposed to navigate
similar to the browser. Basically, you would navigate
and land on a particular node in the
UI.
And in the rule strip, you would determine
what to do with it. So we can
run all sorts of conditions, checks. It's written
in JavaScript.
And then in the end, you would either
raise a warning error,
or you can associate custom icon.
So for example, in this case,
we're going over pods
and then drilling down into containers.
And if the resource limits are not set,
we would say
there are no resources limits set. And then
you can see there are seven such nodes
that are hitting this rule.
On the on the top, you can see
the affected object seven.
And you can see those are the pods
that are
that do not have any resource limits there.
Alright. I'm gonna try and build my own
there. I'm feeling brave.
I'm
gonna cancel this, and I'm gonna say pod
has no
team.
I'm gonna steal your selector.
So I'm just gonna go select
namespace.
Don't worry about Kube system.
We're looking at descendants, which are pods, and
then we have this thing called a script.
Now in a script,
I actually don't need to look at the
containers here. So I'm assuming I could say
if
and
item
config
metadata
dot
labels.
This is gonna be something.
And I wanna do a warning,
No team
owner.
No. This is a map. Is this just
plain JavaScript? Like, actual real stuff? Plain JavaScript.
This is real JavaScript. Alright. So what I
wanna do should be a dictionary. Yeah. Yeah.
So I could say team.
Yeah. That would probably be enough. Right? Because
that would return undefeigned. The team doesn't exist.
Yeah. So I'm gonna create create it.
So
we'll
we'll need to wait a
couple of minutes until there is a next,
next run.
But
Yeah. I think that should work. So I
like that. An easier way to do that.
There is a much easier way to do
that. So while
it's thinking, let's go back to the browser.
Let's
find something real that you would really want
to check.
Because right now, it would raise this,
warning on every single pod. Right? Mhmm. Let's
land on either on NGINX or
somewhere. Maybe we can do run some checks
on top of Argo CD because it's pretty
complex deployment
That was compared with this engine. Cluster.
Oh, or we can go to Kubevious.
Mhmm.
Alright. So Kubevious namespace.
Kubevious.
There is a back end or
the parser, which has service accounts.
We can check for app
permissions or card or MySQL.
Okay.
Basically,
if you decide on which node you want
to run oh, okay. Let's go to container.
So
there is the image. You can run checks
on the image or config maps that are
mounted as environment variables.
So if you go down to the
rule assistant.
Go down. Draw down. Scroll down.
Yeah. Just you can do create new rule
with assistant,
so it would prepopulate
the
the target script. So you can do there
are different syntaxes.
So,
you could use basically
the top example
just to target every single container,
or you can use the
lower one that would target only that one
that you you saw in the UI.
So meaning, the less you specify, the more
broad would be the check. Mhmm. So in
this case, it would basically target every single
namespace application container.
Yep. Otherwise, if you would
use the bottom one, it would be kind
of more specific.
And then if you go to the rule
strip, it would show you the examples of
what would be the values of
different
properties.
So this way, you can anticipate kind of
it's all it gives you some hints what
are the current values of that particular node
so you can
expect what would be the values and what
rules to how to write the rules.
Okay.
I could drop this in like this. This
gives me item config. And then from there
So that would be the result of item
dot config.
And then you can do dot ports or
image.
So, like, this
unsafe image.
And I know that this image is
Kubevious parts or
I'll just copy this.
So we have a target here. It says,
look in all containers.
And as the image is Kubevious parser one
zero eight, I log a warning. But you
said there was other ones here. Can I
do an error? Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Okay. So
Just name it. Allow
parser image.
Maybe we wanna restrict our cluster from running
this specific version because it has a vulnerability
or whatever, and then I I click create.
What I also noticed while we were doing
that is our our pod node team worked.
Yeah.
Mhmm. We can actually see every object.
No. I I mean, I trust you, but
I'm gonna modify that in GenX.
And I'm gonna add labels
team
Rawkode,
and I'll reapply that. So we should see
within the next few minutes that my Rawk
my NGINX partners satisfies
this rule
where it has a two. Okay. So now
if we go to the browser,
that could be the top issue
in the summary since it's it was hitting
couple of
pods.
Okay. So there is if you scroll more,
service account not used, there are probably much
more service accounts than
Yeah. Pods.
Yeah. So that's the rule. So
and those are the instances that are
violating this rule. And those are also clickable.
Once you click, it would navigate into the
corresponding view where you can
do much deeper
debugging.
Nice.
So question Just click on it and Question
or feature request. I'm not sure what I'm
about to give you here. Mhmm. I I
really like these these rules,
but I'm not sure I'd wanna type them
in to the GUI. Can we apply them
via GetOps fashion? Is that something that's on
your road map?
Like, a custom a custom resource definition for
a Kubevious rule that KubeControl applied to my
cluster. That would be really sweet.
I think we can do it. It's
pretty easy. Yeah. Yeah. Mhmm.
Alright. Sorry. You were gonna say something, and
I interrupted you. Yeah. If you I just
want to say, if you click on any
of those links,
let's say the larger namespace, so
it would navigate, and you would be able
to see that yeah. Indeed,
we don't have those we don't have those
labels set on those parts.
Yeah. Scroll down. Yeah. You you will see
the manifest there. Oh, it even is it's
the labels as a separate property
set.
Oh, yeah. There you go. So
for that,
do you mind to open an
issue request on GitHub
No. So that you would be notified whenever
it's there?
Sure.
GitHub
Kubevious.
It can be just one line.
This is what open source is all about.
Right? Yeah.
Feature request.
Right. K.
Make Kubevious
rules
a v r d.
I'll
come back and edit this issue. I promise.
But I have opened. Mhmm. Yeah. Thanks. That's
Alright.
So what are our markers?
Okay.
So things are not always
good or bad, like one or zero.
Sometimes you may want to find things that
are of a special interest to you.
So markers allow you to
check for rules without raising errors,
but instead associating special items
with your workload. So for example, in this
case,
by default, it comes with several monitors.
It's for workloads that use
too many
too much CPU or memory or
or or average size of CPU or memory.
So
this is just an example, and you can
choose color on the icon from the predefined
set. Yeah. I'm pretty happy that I have
my notes here now. Yeah.
So yeah. Yeah. And just like in rules,
it would have affected object.
Right? And
so now it's it's the it's the snowboarder
already.
So you click on it. And the way
you would associate markers is instead of doing
calling the function error or warning,
you would do marker
and the name of the marker. That's it.
So if you go back to the rules,
you would have one of the rules would
do that probably.
Container
memory usage, probably that would be the one.
But can I do it here instead of
having an error unsafe image, which has actually
no match one,
which is great? That's exactly what we wanted.
But I have to say, you know, this
is not an error. So you're saying I
can do marker?
Yeah. You would just say mark
without marker. Yeah. And the name of the
of the titan.
Oh,
should have paid more attention. Just
Meet your memory user. Okay. Just create a
new one. You can just create a new
one. Uh-huh. Alright. Okay. Mark. Yeah.
Livestream.
Yeah. Now we go there.
I don't think it's saved.
Rule oh, no. It does save. Okay. It's
just because I gave it a silly name.
Okay. Oh, yeah.
Yeah. You you you can hide that UI
with the with the
with an interesting naming. Yeah. You just create
new one, add new marker from the top
right corner. I guess we'll need to wait
a few minutes for the rule to rerun.
Oh, you don't have to wait to create
the icon. And once
it's it's run, you can change icons.
Just type a name. Choose the icon.
My livestream.
Alright. Hold on. I have to find the
perfect icon.
Pizza?
Or Yeah. Pizza. That's a good choice. Yeah.
Let's go with an orange pizza.
Cool.
We don't have an effect on the object
yet, but we'll wait. Yeah. Once the rule
runs, then you should Is that what this
icon means? Is that it needs to run
again? It means you yeah. It means you
made some changes that were not yet picked
up.
And during the next run, you would
it should be picked up.
While it's running, there's another capability.
It's a Google live search.
Maybe we can instead of waiting, we can
just try that.
Anything interests you in your cluster? Anything you
wanna find?
Oh, I I'm not sure what I can
search, but let's say I wanted to find
all resources that are tagged with team Rawkode.
Was that something we can do?
Maybe. Let let let's let's try.
Mhmm. I'm just gonna guess. Oh, I get
all complete.
Oh, you're too good to me.
See, that that's joy face. I like it
when that answer. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Nice. So
we can actually see here we have an
application, which has a deployment.
We got NGINX, and we got our
resources on the namespace here.
Okay. When when you give me autocomplete,
I'm a very happy person. Yeah. Let's try.
Let's see my livestream piece. Okay. We're still
waiting on you. So that means medium memory.
I'm
not sure what annotations we have in the
cluster.
Let's see.
Okay. Max replica.
Don't know what the value would be. That
was the silly one to pick.
Vision by? No. That's not gonna work. I
don't know the annotations in my cluster, so
I should stop guessing. Yeah. Yeah.
Or or you just could just use a
free
free text search kind of thing. Yeah.
Alright.
It uses the hierarchy to to find for
things. But since things are kind of loosely
connected,
you can search for
port numbers
or
names of
your apps or config map or your
or,
I mean, volume mount points.
So it's and you can add as many
criteria as you wish to to file to
land on the things that you're interested in.
And it uses,
fuzzy logic. So if you
if you're
even if you make a typo or you're
looking for something
similar to
the term, then you should be able to
find it. Yeah. It's a bit quick.
Nice.
Yeah. That's a really cool feature. I like
the UI and the search there.
They all complete the breakdown of labels and
annotations.
I'd love to be able to filter by
the the image as well.
There's another feature request for you.
Alright. Thanks. Not not
maybe oh, yeah. You can do that. Right?
You can do that from the browser because
yeah. Okay. In the search as well, you
can just type image Kubevious.
That that should work. Just try.
Oh, yeah. No. Just without equals, think you
can even do image space Kubevious,
or you can kind of filter to be
more strict. You can filter by
by client.
By what? Sorry? Website.
There is a the first filter by client,
you can search by
one single type of object. It
will bring you kind of a flat list
of all images used.
Nice. And images used within the namespace or
within an application. So
Yes. So we can actually see Redis here
because that's used by Kubevious. Redis. Yeah.
Alright. Nice.
And I have my livestream marker. Look at
the livestream. Yeah.
This is a lot of really cool components.
I think we should try and summarize
what Kubevious does. I'll try my best to
describe everything that we're kinda sticking to look
at today. And then if you wanna kinda
if you're happy to share what's coming next
for the project, that would be fantastic.
So
my quick one minute summary then of Kubevious
is a tool that I could deploy to
my cluster.
We started off by exploring the browser. The
browser gave us a hierarchical view of all
of the resources within our cluster.
We started off with a high level summary,
and let's just say, let's see some of
the namespaces and stuff that you've got. And
then you provide some sort of a, I
don't know, monitoring observability thing where you can
actually see a breakdown of the top namespaces
and the issues as well, or the issues
within our namespace.
The logic allows us to break down our
cluster
by the types or kinds of resources that
we have, starting off by namespace and then
break it down into
I'm sure I could click that previously.
Yeah. Those are If there's no resources.
Yeah. So if you click on our next
issue, that gets a breakdown. You get to
take a look at the applications, and then
not just the applications, but the containers and
the volume to the service accounts, etcetera. So
really good ways to drill down and understand
what's running on your cluster.
The same happens for images,
for gateway and ingress, which unfortunately we can't
take a look at on my local one.
We also get a look at Helm repositories,
which is something which is actually quite difficult
to do normally. I don't have great visibility
into what Helm stuff is in my cluster,
so that's pretty nice.
And then the RBAC one, I think, is
the cherry on the top of this browser
mode. Like, understanding RBAC in any Kubernetes cluster
is always
it's it's always a huge challenge. And what
I really loved about this feature was the
shared symbol, the one that showed yeah. Here
we go.
This that this role
that role here, the Kubevious contact one, is
actually shared
across multiple service accounts, which is very, very
cool.
We now take a look at guard, which
is a tool that allows you to pass
a manifest to the Kubevious instance inside your
cluster and report on violators,
and the violators are all defined here. You
can disable them or set them up to
be warning or error.
The one thing we didn't cover is
can you add your own validators,
or is that something that's coming later?
Yes. If you wanna participate,
contribute to the project,
you can.
So
for a runtime
addition of web checks, it would the rules
would be used for my deeper integration of
checks, more sophisticated
ones.
They would have to go through the open
source realm.
Okay.
So these validators influence the browser and that
we can see all of the different
errors across all the different resources. On top
of the validators and errors, we have the
ability to write custom rules that can be
deployed to the cluster and scan in resources
for different violations. Here, we scanned for
a specific image that is being used in
the cluster,
and we have the option to set either
a warning on it, an error, or just
a marker. And markers are nice because you
get to pick cool logos and colors, which
just makes it all a lot more pleasing.
So that's that's Kubevious. And if an MS
that you wanna highlight before I ask you
what's coming next?
I think, yeah, that's a really awesome summary.
I would I would probably add that
next, we're gonna definitely fix the guard so
that it would
it would not allow those
violating changes from getting to the cluster.
Except for that, we wanna do more integration
with cloud native
ecosystem. So what I mean by that,
we didn't try
the the gateway. We didn't try addresses, but
there was a recent addition and integration with
traffic proxy.
So if you're a traffic user, Kubevious would
validate that, like, the namings of
middle layers, the TLS options, and things of
that sort that come with traffic.
And if there are any issues, it would
kind of not only render those
configuration in the gateway view, but also would
validate those. So we wanna include more support
for such highly highly rated, highly used popular
open source projects, like
probably it would be in the service mesh
and network policy enforcement.
So that's another area of of high interest
for Kubevious.
We wanna open up rules in
a form of rules library where people can
contribute to a public library and download rules
from the public library as well with some
sort of search engine instead of writing their
own rules manually.
And that's another area for the focus. I
would only add that, of course, we spent
very little bit of time on the types
of rules that we developed right here and
was
one of the most trivial ones that checked
checked one single or or just a couple
of
variables within the manifest.
I think the greatest power comes in when
you would start writing rules that would consider
charts that go across manifest. Let's say, I
wanna find
applications
that have the certain label
and that have certain permissions to my cluster
that have a read access to my secrets
or something from that sort. I think the
greatest power comes from
there.
Awesome.
Very, very cool. I'm
curious about Guard.
Is that something that you see
would become an
a validate in admission controller in the future
rather than a curl locally, or do you
think it's it's more advantageous to have it
blocking or given a warning at CICD? Or
maybe it's a combination of both. Like, how
do you see that playing out?
Because of limitations, it would have to be
a combination of both. Because
in the admission controller,
we can only validate one single manifest at
a time, and we don't have visibility to
other manifest.
Right. There is a limitation. So there are
some ideas to kind of detect whether the
rule spans across manifests,
then it would be have to be validated
from the Dart as a separate
CLI integration or something of that sort.
But the rules that are relatively
trivial, they're kind of self contained.
We would be able to do the validation
in the admission controller as well. So this
way, there would be three levels of validation
starting from the CLI
admission controller,
and there would be
continuous validation that is happening
right now that we've seen in the in
the UI as a final check, which would
be could be used as for auditing purposes
or forensics
or anything of that sort.
Awesome.
Well, this is a really cool project. I
wanna thank you for spending time with me
today and kinda sharing a little bit of
history and motivations
and having a kind of look at each
of the features that are available here.
I've gotta say, like, right off the bat,
the UI is is brilliant. I don't know
who you have on your front end team,
but cherish them and keep them forever because
it looks great. And and Yeah. That that
they're brilliant. Yeah. They're brilliant.
Thanks a lot, David. It was really fun
to
I spent
really fun two hours. It
was really cool to see you jumping
in and writing rules and debugging the issues.
Yeah. And
thanks a lot for your time. It was
really cool. Alright. Well, thank you again. Have
a wonderful weekend, and, hopefully, I'll speak to
you again soon. And to everyone watching Likewise.
Thanks a lot. Likewise. Take care. Ciao.